my name is Claire Dearing and I'm the  founder of the dinosaur protection group  so this is a velociraptor so many people  loved Jurassic world and when you say to  them when was the first time that you  saw a dinosaur hmm I mean you just see  them light up dinosaurs are all so  different there are so many different  species of dinosaurs my mission in life  is to ensure the safety and protection  of these animals what are you going to  do to make sure that your children have  the same experience that you did you can  help ensure their survival  go to our website browse around sign up  for our newsletter are you going to be a  part of the generation who decided to  have dinosaurs go extinct or will you be  on board with making sure that dinosaurs  can stay alive for future generations we  must save the dinosaurs  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Applause]  [Music]  you